la colère d'une partie des haïtiens
contre je venais le moïse ne faiblit pas
ils étaient plusieurs milliers à
manifester ce dimanche dans plusieurs
villes d'haïti contre leur président les
manifestants dénoncent des velléités de
dictature de la part du pouvoir en place
et le climat d'insécurité qui règne dans
le pays
je venais le moïse a été élu en 2015
lors d'un scrutin annulé pour fraude
puis élu de nouveau un an plus tard mais
selon l'opposition son mandat de cinq
ans date du premier scrutin et non de
son entrée en fonction voilà pourquoi
elle ne le reconnaît plus comme
président légitime l'article 134 points
2 de la constitution haïtienne dit que
le mandat du président est terminée eh
bien nous avons un président qui est en
rébellion avec la loi qui est là pour
défendre la loi la justice
nous avons clairement dit que nous
sommes sous la dictature le peuple nous
a demandé de prendre la décision de
descendre dans la rue avec le peuple de
dieu pour faire entendre sa voix auprès
de la communauté internationale
la marche pacifique s'est déroulée sans
incident ni confrontation avec les
forces de l'ordre dans la capitale un
véhicule qui diffusait de la musique
d'ambiance a chaviré faisant plusieurs
blessés ce qu'a déploré jeu venelles
moïse
j'ai été informé de l'accident d'un char
qui animait la marche de ce 28 février
et des victimes parmi les participants
ont été recensés je déplore ce drame et
présente mes sympathies à leurs proches
je me tiens aux côtés des haïtiens dont
les bons comme dans les mauvais moments
privés de parlement est isolé je venais
le moïse gouvernent par décret
alimentant une défiance croissante au
sein de la population face à la grogne
populaire le président haïtien a annoncé
l'organisation du premier tour des
élections présidentielle et législatives
en septembre un référendum
constitutionnel est également prévue
pour juin